hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
ac.l2-3.1.19 encrypt cui on mobile
devices and mobile Computing platforms
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone try to understand all of this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions which is where we
help you transform into your company's
on-call compliance hero and get this
stuff let's jump into it so in cmfcc
control ac.l
2-3.1.19 encrypt cui on mobile devices
and mobile Computing platforms this is
another pretty clear-cut control which
sets a mandate for how mobile devices
must have data protected now the
interesting thing here is the question
what's a mobile device right it's not
really so clear-cut if you just read the
control to answer that we look at nist
definitions for mobile devices which
reference any Computing platform which
may store process or transmit data
particularly cui in this case which is
considered portable okay so this
includes just as just as a few relevant
examples laptops tablets mobile phones
Etc which are meant to be not in a fixed
position or a fixed place so yes tablets
and laptops as well as smartphones must
have encryption turned on if they will
store process or transmit cui I know
what you're thinking you're thinking all
right well look man if I work hard
enough I could probably make you know a
desktop computer portable and you're
right but we do have definitions from
this to help us out there so again it's
something that's meant to be portable
and again we just sort of use a little
bit of Common Sense there I think
that'll help us all out I mean let's be
honest when dealing with these controls
a little Common Sense goes a little a
long way all right let's check out what
the assessors are looking for and how to
make them happy so uh if I'm assessing
this control again there's two main
primary assessment points the first one
is determining if mobile devices and
mobile Computing platforms that process
store transmit cui are identified in
other words do you know what they are
are they somehow identified that these
are the mobile devices and we need to
keep track of these all right these need
to be protected in a special way if I
was giving you a sample answer I would
say hey mobile device are identified by
System naming convention right we can
name them so we can easily spot them in
active directory and Via Network
inventory documentation right we've got
that we've got things documented
and our Baseline configuration inventory
so we know what's portable or mobile and
we know what is not uh now the second
assessment Point uh determine if
encryption is employed to protect cui on
identified mobile devices and mobile
Computing platforms uh again if I was
giving a sample answer that I might say
something like hey encryption is
employed via I don't know maybe
BitLocker I think symante's got some
great products for encryption uh and
Group Policy enforces it right so maybe
we're enforcing a group policy maybe
you've got a third-party solution like
again I mentioned Symantec earlier
they've got some Drive encryption stuff
that can enforce it it's use within all
computers in the OU that has access to
cui so again in this particular sample
answer that I'm giving we're talking
about an organizational unit with an
active directory that's been designated
the cui organizational unit there's lots
of ways to segment information but
that's one of them so uh and on call we
work with defense contractors just like
you who have had this dfar's nist itar
and cmmc compliance stuff dropped into
their lap like a seagull on a sunny day
baby we teach you how to level up and be
a proper on-call compliance hero for
your company eliminating gaps gray areas
and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
as your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
and that's what becoming an on-call
compliance Bureau can do for you if
you're looking for more help getting
compliant or just figure out what your
mobile devices are our compliance
experts are always on call for you you
can visit cmmccompliance secrets.com or
check out the bio below for links to get
help right now if you love the content
we're putting out here for you help us
out with a big thumbs up on that like
button it really helps us out Keeps Us
motivated here back at the home base all
right we're even better smash the
Subscribe button guys we get so excited
we get no subscribers it's like a dance
party in our Halls every day when that
happens all right smash the Subscribe
button get a compliance nerve to do a
little dance and we'll videotape it
we'll put it on do all right until the
next supplies tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]